oh look at you
you look like a dream
i look like i'm going to the proms
well you are i mean you've got my
corsage you are at the prom and you're
the queen of the prom the homecoming
queen yes you are the homecoming queen
getting a lifetime achievement i
couldn't think of anyone more deserving
how does that feel when your peers
other actors are saying
this one
i have to say it's absolutely amazing i
joined sag when i first came to america
to make a film in the late 70s i think
it was
2010 and um
[Music]
it's not just it's coming from my peers
it's the fact that's coming from
american actors i have to say is
particularly important for me because i
was even when i was in england you know
doing theater i was a great admirer of
american film acting and i still am um i
i just find what what american actors do
on film is extraordinary and and you
know we we all watched that and tried to
learn from it so
so receiving it from my fellow american
actors is is very important when you
think about a lifetime achievement does
it make you start to think about what
your legacy
will be and is and what do you want your
legacy to be
gosh you know we all we come and go all
of us as actors you know there are and
and you have your moment you have your
moment in the sun if you're lucky and i
have had that moment and tonight is very
much a part of that and then you pass on
and you pass it on to someone else you
know you pass the torch if you like yes
to someone else and and you understand
that that is a natural part of
of life um
you know the great thing about film
acting is that your performances can
live for a long time and i don't know
about you but i love watching old movies
and watching these some of these
extraordinary performances of actors
that you you know we've forgotten their
names but um
anyway i i just want to have been
you know i hope
respectful and and a creative
member of of the acting profession in
the time that i was allotted to me well
you did that you definitely did that do
you have something in your head that you
feel like this is my greatest
accomplishment to date i was just
re-watching the queen the other day and
i was like i was just gobsmacked by you
we've had a lot of great queens yes
since i did that um
you know i i think it's not one role
it's it's the multiplicity of roles and
and the variety of roles and that's what
i've always tried to do is constantly
mix it up so i could go from i think the
film i did after the queen immediately
after the queen was fast and furious yes
it was
and then you're gonna be a villain in
shazam guys yeah
that's what i love is there anyone out
there because you've done so much anyone
out there that you're saying i still
want to work with them
oh my god they're almost all here
tonight absolutely many many of them
many of them uh you know some great
great actors here tonight and actresses
of course so you know i like the word
actress myself